[upbeat music]
How are late cars is still a thing?
If the millions of data points available were tracked in real time;
weather, street closures, emergencies, historical trends,
cars might never be late again.
All that usable data could create a more efficient and reliable subway system too.
Processing split second rider-data and track conditions to predict and avoid any breakdowns.
And what about commerce?
Smarter banking could easily spot a single fraudulent transaction among billions of real ones, in a matter of seconds.
Cell phones...
If they had more processing power and
higher through-puts
I'd have 10 million more noobs in the palm of my hands.
Even food...
Every plant, fruit or vegetable could have its own IP address
by growing them in ultra-efficient smart farms.
Processing countless data sources such
as soil nutrients, air quality, humidity,
irrigation and more.
Insights could be collected to help grow the perfect
'whatever you want'
every single time...
...wherever you want.